-Oh, look at that!
Oh, look at that!
That's what I'm talking --
That is a friend right there.
-Look what I stole
from your show.
-That is a friend.
No, that is a gift.
Do you see --
You probably didn't even see,
but when you take a sip,
there's another bonus logo
on the bottom.
It's upside down, but whatever.
We'll fix it later.
It's for people with left --
Hey, yeah, that's what
I'm talking about!
"All About Steve."
-That was a lot of bourbon.
I drank like half
a thing of bourbon.
-Joel, what is
"All About Steve"?
Is that that --
-My favorite movie of all time?
-Yeah.
-This is Sandra Bullock,
who is, like, super famous.
Bradley Cooper, super famous.
Then we got Thomas Hayden
Church, Oscar nominee,
and then this guy --
I don't know who he is.
I think it's Ken Jeong.
He was in this thing.
I have no idea.
I do a podcast with Ken, and
that movie had all the razzies,
so I just make fun of him
endlessly.
-Why not?
That's what friends are for.
See, Ken?
-Look at him.
-That's what friends are for.
Come on.
-Yeah. And they're really
mocking his height
in this -- in this poster.
-[ Laughs ] Gosh.
-Welcome to my -- Yeah, you like
how I chose an abandoned office
for the interview?
-I like that you dressed up.
You look sharp.
You look great as always.
And I always appreciate you
coming on.
You're glitching a bit now,
which is good because it makes
me look better.
You look like Max Headroom.
-No. You look like Where's Waldo
on vacation.
I like it.
-[ Laughs ]
-Or like you're
a gondola driver.
-[ Laughs ]
Do they wear blazers?
-The gondola --
Oh, the gondola drivers?
-Yeah.
-No.
You look like you're a gondola
driver going to First Communion.
Like, you're like, "Giuseppe, I
must become a --"
Sorry. You know what you're
dressed like, I think, Jimmy?
You're dressed like
a cool mega preacher.
-Mm. Like "Ozark," one of those
dudes, like, on the boat?
That guy? Or like a Joel Osteen?
-Like Joel Osteen. Yeah, now
they're all, like, hip.
Like Justin Bieber's pastor.
They, like, wear cool stuff
and they're always working out
and posting it.
That's what you look like.
That's a compliment.
-[ Laughs ]
God, I wish I was working out.
I got to start working out.
What's your workout routine?
What do you do?
What's in your --
What's in your workout routine?
-My wife and I usually --
We work out together,
so we usually, like, uncork like
a white, like a Pinot Grigio.
-[ Laughs ]
-And then we go right to
the red and then the hard stuff.
-[ Laughs ]
I got to say I've been listening
to the podcast
that you've done with your pal
Ken Jeong, who we do love.
That was cool,
but I didn't even know --
I knew you guys worked together.
I didn't know you were
actual friends.
-Thank you for mentioning that
we worked together.
We were on a little show on NBC
called "Parks and Rec."
-Oh, close. "Community."
Same week.
You were on the same week.
-I just want to say working with
Chris Pratt and Amy Poehler
was just some of the most fun
I've ever had on a show.
-Yeah. Well, maybe one day
you'll work with them.
-Oh, yeah.
Ken and I started the podcast
because he --
It's called
"The Darkest Timeline,"
which is a thing
from "Community."
And Ken is a real doctor.
He was a terrible doctor, and he
was thrown out of medicine.
He was sued, and I want everyone
to know that.
-That is not true.
Is that really true?
-Maybe.
So he knows what he's talking
about, and I'm an idiot.
-Ah.
-So it was me just kind of
talking to him about what was
happening with COVID
at the time, and then we began
inviting friends on.
And so we've had --
It's been great.
We've had, like,
the "Community" cast on,
and then Ken knows
a bunch of people.
-Well, it's a funny show.
I would encourage anyone
to go on it.
Have you learned anything?
-Wait. You have a podcast yet?
-No.
-You should make
time for podcasts
because it -- you would --
-I think so.
That's where we're going.
That's where we're headed?
-Yeah.
I mean, I think you'd be great.
-Is the goal of a podcast
to just be the podcast
or would you want to end up
hosting the show
or like a TV show?
-I would like to create
kind of a Ponzi scheme
where I take people's money
and eventually tell them
they're going to make more
money, and then I run away
to a country where
they can't find me.
-I've gotten e-mails from --
yeah, yeah, I can forward you
some interesting places.
-I'm sorry I haven't really
answered any of your questions
in a real way.
-That's why we have you on.
You're a comedian. You're funny.
You've been a great guest
on our show.
I'm not necessarily sure
if we want the answer.
-True. Do you want to see
my biggest joke so far?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Look.
Hilarious.
It's shorts with a suit!
[ Laughs ]
I'm sorry. That was really dumb.
-It actually really
made me laugh. I loved it.
I thought it was
very, very funny.
I appreciate you wearing the tie
and dressing up. It looks good.
-That's because I've become
a Mormon missionary,
and so I've been going around.
Everyone's home. It's great.
-[ Laughs ]
I guess so.
It's good for business, sure.
There's more to talk about.
I do want to
talk about "Community."
There's lots of things
I want to talk to you about,
and, of course, "Card Sharks."
-And I want to know what you did
for the last two weeks.
-I got tan.
-You look good.
Did you go to Long Island?
-[ Laughs ]